Souls can read [ __ ] subscribe
in step can lock button
hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
John Humphrey we're gonna watch the
trailer for Rob Zombie's 3 from hell
John is a huge huge huge Rob Zombie fan
most of his movies only when I miss his
Lords of Salem and the real rejects
title was inspired by the Devil's
Rejects really shows in our work I film
I watched with my mother in the theaters
it's the right movie a watcher they're
your family any teenagers or little kids
who are watching listen before we go
into this I want to give an earth thank
you to the folks over at dark web for
allowing me to host their comic-con
panel just got back this weekend yeah
the show is actually really good I've
seen the whole thing this is really good
seriously go watch it it's an 8 episode
series Amazon exclusive has a pretty
good amount of well-known people and
there it's like a serialized anthology
tale I feel like I could call it tales
from the dark web in a way there's a
little worried it wouldn't be good but
it was good anyway well let's watch this
I know not everyone's gonna watch our
reaction for this
I know Lionsgate doesn't usually a lot
of people monetize her stuff and
probably her as yellow dollar will sign
the Devil's Rejects means something to
John and I
search for the fugitives known as the
Devil's Rejects resulted in a violent
clash with police chances for survival
unless
[Applause]
free the free
[Music]
just a clown basically the chains a band
what the hell
this is very dense factory oh my god
oh damn
[Music]
today
[Music]
[Music]
that's a that's a Rob Zombie trailer
right there Oh a thousand person wonder
if he cut that himself I'm fascinated by
this movie because I remembered hearing
talks about Devil's Rejects and he was
like kind of anti sequel and he was
saying like you really wanted to end it
you know not just keep setting up for
franchises I remember exactly what he
said was a long time ago when Devil's
Rejects came out and I know filmmakers
like many artists are susceptible to
changing their mind like you know what I
actually have a sequel and even though I
was saying no I want to end it right
here people can be [ __ ] about ending
their movie yeah yeah and then he comes
out with three from Hell mm-hm so I'm
wondering what this is really gonna all
be it's kind of ridiculous that they
survived that shooting yeah you're
throwing the dialogue of like a million
to one and everything but I feel like
there was a satanic revival or whatever
yeah so I'm fascinated into seeing what
realm this goes into because house of a
thousand Corpses was the first one which
had a much more campy tone to it
and I thought that what he did with
Devil's Rejects I still find to be
personally my favorite film of his
Murphy and surprisement even Ebert a
rope or like really good yeah I liked
having a bit of that more realistic
handheld touch and this just seems very
much Rob Zombie Unleashed he feels more
grungy more grindhouse than ever super
duper in-your-face I'm more drawn to the
parts in this trailer when they're being
interviewed this whole idea of this
family has always sort of been a bit of
a commentary on like the Manson Family
in a way or inspired from to a certain
degree
watching that like archive use footage
isn't just gonna be a montage where's I
gonna be like a whole Act or half of the
movie because that was the part of this
that seemed the most intriguing to me
seeing how the people are responding to
them how some of the people are like
free the three I think is an interesting
concept to go down people are supporting
and rooting for them and
them and their personalities but how sir
thousands of corpses had that cult feel
with the family and then here it seems
like there art of helping it kind of
following so maybe it is bringing it
full circle that was a part that was the
most fascinating to me yeah I mean since
this movie picked up steam the
advertising especially like the early
stuff that Rob Zombie's been leaking out
was mostly in that prison setting I mean
he started putting out the three the
three slogan and the images of them
doing the mug shots right uh you know
ages ago so I feel like he's been
teasing that aspect of the movie a whole
lot and if I know anything about Rob
Zombie I know him to be pretty pragmatic
about things when it comes to this I've
heard him say and interviews multiple
times over the years when talking about
his other projects he wants to make he
said basically if I wanted to make
Devil's Rejects three I could do that in
a heartbeat
and I've got all these other ideas I
want to work on and so he's had
Tyrannosaurus Rex which was supposed to
happen that didn't happen he had his
Groucho Marx movie that was supposed to
be his big for a out of horror which
thus far has not materialized not to
mention his Broad Street Bullies film
about the Philadelphia Flyers so part of
me wonders if maybe this was a sort of
like well I want to make a movie and if
this is the movie I can make then I'll
come up with something new guys yeah
exactly something else I know about Rob
Zombie he usually rises to an occasion
at the very least even if you don't like
it even if you don't think it's
particularly good so I'm curious to see
what he does with this I'm glad he's not
ignoring the fact that they were in a
devastating shootout at the end of the
last movie yeah so at least I'm very
curious to see how he builds his way out
of that one and the nice thing about
this particular little mini franchise
here is that part of the charm is that
the first in the second movie are so
different in tone and style from one
another and this trailer kind of gives
me both yeah exactly so I'm kind of
thinking about thirty one right now
calcium thousand Corpses has a cult
fanatic element in the kids who go
searching out these different roadside
oddities and they go way too far by
investing in the Firefly plan in the
second movie you see what that obsession
can be like from a position of direct
effect and power or something like that
so yeah I hope that this movie does
touch on the fanaticism over serial
killers that's especially
gotten really huge these days because
you look back on these people talking
about
I just watched an episode of dark
journal if I ever where he was at some
kind of Jeffrey Dahmer convention thing
and people really latch on to these
figures and we'll kind of rationalize
them and and speak for their character
in reference to their actions or in
contrast from their actions so I hope
that this movie can take some of that
you ever think it's like feigning
interest though I don't know and the
pure what the word feigning is today so
he's my ID I don't think serial killers
are gonna be done feigning that
interesting in a very small amount of
time but it's people I mean like I like
how his troupe keeps growing Richard
breaks in here who played doom head and
31 who everybody who kind of agreed was
the one agreeable part of that movie
Jeff Daniel Phillips I think always
shines in Rob Zombie's stuff just
curious to see who else gets dragged
into this
oh yeah he's back I thought he died in
the first one but you know he's just
like Rob Rodriguez's yeah yeah cuz man
how many times to kill him off in the
franchise he's gonna come back a movie
come back when it comes to Rob Zombie
there's a lot out there that tries to
emulate the grindhouse feel and that
sensibility and of all the lives he
lives it and whether or not for better
for worse whether you like his movie or
not I feel like he authentically brings
that kind of filmmaking to life and so
that seems to continue here to me yeah
his films are very unsettling yeah you
know they're all like loud southern
characters we're super in your face in a
weird way they seem authentic from him
and they don't feel forced they feel
like forces of their own nature yeah and
I think that's why Halloween one was a
little weird because you're very much
out of that context for it is like
trying to splice it into with that but
it didn't work as well but here I'm like
no this is Rob Zombie unleash and I like
how I got laid you said it is a hybrid
of both the first and second one maybe
he will go down some like borderline you
know do you satanic supernatural thing
because they don't look injured at all
their scars should be noticeable or
there should be some type of injury to
them because
cutting other parts in the trailer where
they're in action and clearly out of
prison it's like it look like they never
were in the craziest long yeah Freebird
shootout you're everything and that's
something too I feel like because the
first one is like Texas Chainsaw two
it's just kind of like crazy hillbillies
and the second one is like a weird
messed up Western a satanic supernatural
vibe could be a cool element to add in
because it's just one step further you
know because we've seen like ghouls and
stuff in the first movie weirdly it's
the only logical way I could see this
yeah and I feel like he may be going
with that with the satanic resurrection
super imposition of those words yeah I
mean you have like dr. Satan in the
first one thing all the Devil's Rejects
in the second one when you felt a lot
more of me no I know about the word for
I was grounded be let's say that
grounded in it not supernatural yeah I
feel like it would fit so maybe he'll do
it and I'm glad to see sid haig is still
kicking
cuz this actually came out on his
birthday last week but he's looking very
frail now so I'm hoping he's all right
I'll be fine you'll see
yeah went for text when he'll for ever
comes out rejects for life or whatever
the next one is he'll be back alright
guys well are you excited for three from
hell
this one was just for us not a single
person requested well you guys can
subscriber the real rejects click that
notification bell and we'll definitely
be watching this movie we definitely
will we must complete the trilogy comes
to us